joining us in the studio is professor
haike rao from the german aerospace
center
planetary researcher now we've heard
there are 500 million habitable planets
in our cosmic neighborhood so how long
will it take till we discover life out
there well it will still take a bit
because we don't really know if they are
habitable we really think there's every
second planet every second star has a
planet out there but we don't yet know
if they have life but but
are you sure we will discover it someday
i mean is there anything like aliens or
maybe just green slime what do you
expect well the critical question of
course i personally believe that life
did not only form on earth and if
there's life out there and it's a bit
similar to us then we have a good chance
to find it and could you imagine
anything else in a completely different
form from the type of life we have
well life has to follow the biological
and chemical principles so it will
probably be more or less like we find it
on earth and if it's very very different
to be honest we wouldn't find it because
we wouldn't know how to identify
what are actually the signals you're
looking for to detect life well if you
want to detect modern life on earth you
would look for oxygen
if you would want to detect life on the
early earth where i formed you would
look for probably for me science so
you're looking for four key
key molecules which are
very abundant in the atmosphere and that
we can find in spectra of of planets
now it's probably really interesting to
find more and more exoplanets but what
are the real insights you can get for
research maybe also about our own solar
system well what we learned is that the
other solar systems that we discovered
so far are very very different from the
solar system we have something like a
big gas planet like jupiter but with an
orbit of only a day around the sun so
very hot several thousand degrees hot we
have found planets more massive than
earth
ten times the mass of earth what we have
not found is a planetary system
identical to the solar system and this
is not because it's not out there it's
simply because technically the past
missions and even the kepler mission
could not find it so earth is not
exceptional
earth is probably not exceptional but we
still have the challenge to find the
so-called second earth so really a
planet that's similar to us that's why
we are planning new missions to follow
kepler now
is there actually a chance to get maybe
kepler back into operation no they will
they will use kepler
for other purposes but for planetary
research no unfortunately not and we in
europe are now planning a new mission to
follow kepler and and complete the task
tell us more about it how will you
proceed
well what we want to do is build a
follow the technique that kepler is
using but have a much wider field of
view scan one million stars and find
hundreds of small earth-like planets and
these planets will be
around stars which are so bright that
then for these stars we can look for
these spectroscopic signals and see if
they have an atmosphere and if they have
life so we can hope can we help we can
hope what's the time schedule
well to find these planets if we get
these uh missions we will find these
planets in the next decade but to find
life of them will take a few more
decades i'm afraid thanks a lot for the
talk thank you